[Music]
in the time it's going to take me to
read this intro one of zak king's videos
can tell an entire story and dazzle you
while doing it his digital vignettes
have amassed king an enormous following
especially on tick tock where he has 65
million followers i paid a visit to king
at his studio southeast of la to get a
peek behind the curtain
south america that sounds fun hey
you might need this imagine building
your very own shortcut from the airport
hey how much are they painting oh a
hundred dollars cool
or driving off in a painting you buy at
an art fair
zach king can this is a really good deal
actually and it's those digital slights
of hand
that he's become best known for
we think the social media feed is kind
of a dark place it can be from that dark
place king's mission is to brighten
things up bringing a little more wonder
into the world 15 seconds at a time
that's a great thing yeah i really love
delighting people and taking them on
this this little story arc of wonder
surprise and delight all within a short
period of time but at the end of the day
the 15 seconds has to be a story that
resonates uh take a step to the right
and they have to go oh i understand that
scenario but here's the way zack you
know was able to tackle in a fun
surprising way that can include zooming
back to the future
or even just floating in a room
where do you find inspiration for these
videos i think when you look at
childlike wonder one of the reasons we
lose that as adults is because we have
these assumptions about things oh you
left a toy there mason hold on but when
i approach a video with my team we're
looking at these different items
[Music]
or stories without the assumptions that
we've already attached them and that
allows us to like for example look at a
pool table and playing pool but then
also it turns into a real pool and the
blue felt turns into water
what's fun about this is we get to
experiment we get to build all kinds of
sets and
in here when you walk around is like an
eclectic i don't know how to describe it
it's eclectic there's sets for
everything you could say what king has
built is his field of streams so you
have literally created your own studio
here yeah this is the playground uh this
is a fun room this is a rotating room
like on the bottom right now looks like
a golf course but when you rotate it
might be a basketball course and on the
top it's a soccer field kitchen set and
everything's always just being set
decked and changed and there's of course
like a race course going throughout yeah
right now we just did a video that was
actually with another youtube channel
called dude perfect and we race through
here and all these different illusions
this is a fun room the technical term
for it is an ames room it really depends
on camera but like we're close enough if
you walk down there
you'll really shrink and then all start
to grow in size and and then have a high
little voice yeah exactly
at 31 years old zach king has already
compiled a massive catalog of
accomplishments
[Music]
this has to feel amazing to you as to
what you've created already in your life
does it yeah i think a lot of people
view
our success as an overnight success like
when we watch it it's been a slow
journey yeah that journey began as a kid
in
oregon so
we'll start off with your name when king
would recreate movies at his house using
his parents home video camera and his
sisters
even the family dog
as actors
when you went to go to college though
you hit a little bit of a road bump
almost an obstacle that some people
might be deterred you weren't i was a
junior in high school i like already
knew i was going to go to film school
down in l.a next stephensville and yeah
that was my dream applied to film school
and didn't get in and that turned to me
to youtube actually i want to take you
to a whole new level king began posting
free tutorials on movie effects
the feedback from viewers turned out to
be priceless it was like hey these are
cool tutorials but you're really missing
like the narrative like we want to see
like how would you use the lightsaber
effect in a video like give us like that
demo film
so we made this jedi kittens it went
viral with 24 million views leading to a
sequel
jedi kittens strike back
and more direction for king's future
when i was graduating college all my
colleagues were going off to kind of do
that a traditional hollywood pet and i
was at the stage where my my youtube
channel was at maybe 300 000 subscribers
i was making about 1200 a month so i was
like i could pay my rent and i just had
a hunch that the side of innovation was
probably going to be online and not in
the traditional space and maybe offer a
back door into that this is how i
hitchhike
king's break came with vine a social
media site for six second videos he says
he didn't have any actors he could use
so he put himself on camera
copying and pasting money vine would
eventually go under but it helped king's
career take off
he now has more than 100 million
followers across social media do you
think of yourself as a tick tocker as a
youtuber depends on the day and who i'm
talking to my job title will will change
but i think at the end of the day most
of us in the studio call ourselves
filmmakers or at a broader level just
storytellers on the internet this year i
might be known as a tick talker excuse
me yes can you make some change next
year who knows what the platform will be
or in a couple years and not to get too
personal but
this is a very lucrative career for you
now right
parents out there you do very well
there's a lot of people that come up and
they're like hey how do i be a youtuber
because they see the fame of it or they
see the money let's go for it all right
let's queue rain that's not why we do it
but for us it's awesome because it keeps
paying the bills i'm just wondering if
these white pads at all are gonna be a
problem i get to collaborate with like
25 awesome people every week on my team
and king has realized the fun isn't just
making the magic it's also revealing the
illusion what's cool
is not just a reveal on the mirror and
the long board but if you're like
watching it you can see the mirror
shadow there like the whole time do you
want to ever get back to more of the
long form filmmaking more than 15
seconds yeah yeah for us we want to do
longer stories it's finding the right
story and developing that because for a
long time i was like well to tell a long
story we need two years of time but the
internet doesn't have two years of time
your channels will die so is there a
realm where both
coexist together that's what we're
trying to figure out until then zach
king will continue to enjoy his current
reality
while anti-gravity rain is impossible
for now
15 seconds at a time
no
when you're at this point you have to
pinch yourself once in a while like slap
yourself to like realize like okay this
is awesome this is cool like
the kid in me if you told me when i was
10 years old that i have a studio
playground and a team of awesome
creative people to create with like i
would have fainted you know
do what you love and the money will
follow